Trump has been gagged multiple times um
by the court yes uh as soon as multiple
gag orders had been issued it seemed
like Trump has violated them and that's
going to be a whole thing and I know we
did a whole video on how Trump was
claiming he was under a gag order when
he wasn't well now the gag orders are
really coming down US District Judge
Tanya chin has heard enough and after a
2-hour hearing about Donald Trump's
habit calling prosecutors and Witnesses
Liars Thugs and traitors the judge has
issued an order barring him for making
any public statements targeting
Witnesses lawyers and Court staff now
the order applies to all parties but so
far only one of them has been suggesting
that some witness kind of sort of maybe
should have been executed and that
person is Donald Trump judge chuin said
Trump can quote assert his belief that
this prosecution is politically
motivated but his quote First Amendment
freedoms do not allow him to launch a
pre-trial smear campaign so of course
Trump quickly exercised his Free Speech
rights and blasted the order I'll be the
only politician in history that runs
with a gag order where I'm not allowed
to criticize people can you imagine this
do you believe this I'm not allowed to
criticize people so we'll see we'll
appeal it and we'll see but it's it's so
un so unconstitutional now after the
justice department indicted Trump in DC
Trump vented on Truth social if you go
after me I'm coming after you now there
are obviously many ways you can
interpret that statement Trump did not
identify anyone by name nor was it even
clear his comment was about the DC case
he could have been talking about any of
the people on his enemy list such as
Barack Obama Hillary Clinton or the
editors who dropped him from the Forbes
400 list however the government contends
that Trump was obviously talking about
the DC prosecution special Council Jack
Smith said Trump subsequently quote made
good on his Threat by making
inflammatory comments about the case on
an almost daily basis for example Trump
described judge chuckin as a biased
Trump hating judge who deserves a filthy
and crimer ridden District that is over
95% anti-trump he also posted derogatory
things about Bill bar and Mike Pence so
Smith filed a motion asking the court to
stop Donald Trump from making public
statements attacking the citizens of the
District of Columbia the court
prosecutors and prospective Witnesses
prosecutors said that quote Trump's
Relentless public posts marshalling
anger and mistrust in the justice system
have already influenced the public for
instance on August 5th 2023 police
arrested Abigail Joe Shri for making
quote racist death threats to judge
chuen the government also said the
jurors are already fearful of lowback by
Angry Trump supporters citing the
criminal trial Brandon fellows a trump
supporter who was at the capital on
January 6 you might recall that during
the trial the jury sent the court a note
expressing concern that fellows might
have information about the identity of
jurors but naturally Trump opposed the
motion he argued that gag order would be
a prior restraint on political speech
that would violate his first amendment
rights quote the Biden Administration
charged president Trump the leading
contender in the 2024 presidential
election for statements he made as
president now keenly aware that it is
losing the race for 2024 the prosecution
seeks to unconstitutionally silence
president Trump's but not President
Biden's political speech on pain of
contempt and Trump argued that the court
has less Draconian tools to ensure a
fair trial including a change of venue
postponement of the trial extensive
searching of prospective jurors and
sequestration of the jurors as well
those are arguably less restrictive
options than the blanket protective
order and Trump wasn't wrong Americans
have First Amendment rights to freedom
of speech and criminal defendants have a
constitutional right to a fair trial and
you don't give up those rights even when
you are accused of 90 something
crimes problem Jud but there are I where
a person's right to a fair trial can be
in conflict with someone else's Free
Speech rights if there is too much
commentary about a case it can taint the
jury pool now this is a fairly
underdeveloped part of constitutional
law because criminal defendants rarely
have such a burning desire to make
pre-trial statements uh as well as the
means to fight the court when they issue
these types of orders but the Supreme
Court has held that judges can limit
attorney speech when a lawyer's words
have a substantial likelihood of
materially prejudicing a legal
proceeding in Gentile versus State Bar
of Nevada the court said that that
attorneys aren't entitled to the same
degree of protection as the media but
what if a person is making incendiary
statements as a criminal defendant well
the Supreme Court has never explained
which standard applies to the speech of
a criminal defendant let alone the
standard that applies to a person
running for president in Trump's case
the government argued that the court
should apply the standard articulated in
Gentile versus State Bar of Nevada well
Trump argued that the Gentile standard
only applies to lawyers Trump contended
any speech restrictions on defendants
must survive strict scrutiny meaning
that the government must prove that any
prohibited speech would constitute a
clear and present danger to the
administration of justice at the hearing
judge tuken announced that she would
sidestep the issue of the proper
standard she said quote I intend for any
order I issue to meet to satisfy either
test now as you can probably tell Trump
is going to need a good lawyer to fight
all these gag orders but if you want a
great lawyer my firm the eagle team can
help if you've had an injury or death in
the family suffered a data breach or
were involved in a car crash we can
represent you or help find you the right
attorney who can because getting a
lawyer right away is so important to
make sure you get a full recovery just
click on the link in the description for
free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team link is down below
now back to all the gag orders but
different courts have different rules in
Trump's New York hush money case judge
Juan Manuel mkin issued a protective
order uh preventing Trump from publicly
discussing the evidence disclosed during
the discovery process the order also
prevents Trump from receiving the names
or other identifying information about
people who work for prosecutor Alvin
Bragg other than prosecutors and law
enforcement members until the start of
jury selection however judge murkin
refused to characterize this as a gag
order he said he would not impose a gag
order because quote such restraints are
the most serious and least tolerable on
First Amendment rights that does apply
doubly to Mr Trump because he is a
candidate for the presidency of the
United States in merkin's view uh the
government would need to show that
Trump's speech presented to clear and
present danger before he would restrict
it in Trump's New York Civil Trial uh
judge Arthur Enron issued a limited gag
order after Trump posted a photo of the
judge's clerk with Chuck Schumer along
with a link to her private Instagram
profile but judge angron was not amused
he said quote consider the statement a
gag order forbidding all parties from
posting on social media about members of
his Staff Judge angron did not limit
Trump from speaking about the judge
though in Washington DC the local
federal court rules are stricter in
order to avoid interfering with a fair
trial or prejudicing the administration
of justice rule 57.7 prohibits anyone
from making a public statement about
quote the identity testimony or
credibility of prospective Witnesses and
any opinion as to the accused guilt or
innocence or as to the Merit of the case
or the evidence in the case if the case
is a widely publicized or Sensational
criminal case the court on motion of
either party or its own motion May issue
a special order governing such matters
as extrajudicial statements by parties
Witnesses and attorneys likely to
interfere with the rights of the accused
to a fair trial by an impartial jury the
seating and conduct in the courtroom of
Spectators and news media
Representatives the management and
sequestration of jurors and Witnesses
and other matters which the court May
deem appropriate for inclusion in such
an order a trump Ally Roger Stone ran a
foul of this rule when he posted
photograph of Judge Amy Burman Jackson
with crosshairs superimposed over her
image the judge said Stone was trying to
quote Jin up more public comments and
controversy about the legitimacy of the
Muller investigation the house
investigation and to get people to
question the legitimacy of the
prosecution she concluded that stone was
acting in a manner that would pose a
substantial likelihood of material
Prejudice now the gag order hearing in
front of Judge chuckin went about as
well as you might expect uh the judge
went through several of Trump's
statements asking both sides to comment
about whether Trump's comments
interfered with a fair trial or
Prejudice the ad ministration of Justice
or The credibility of witnesses a judge
chucken was most concerned about whether
Trump's statements about the judicial
system and his employees violated local
rules she said she was aware of and did
not care about what Trump said about her
but she was appalled by Trump's comments
about Judge angron's clerk she wanted to
know if John Loro Trump's attorney
agreed that such statements were out of
bounds Loro said he would advise Trump
that such comments were a bad idea but
he also argue the quote nothing has
happened like that in this case and
nothing like that will happen judge Chen
was skeptical Laurel said there's no
need for an order because when a judge
or lawyer tells Trump to do something he
does it quote because if your honor
makes that kind of admonition it will be
followed and it has been followed lauro
really did say that but without cameras
in the courtroom I don't know if he said
that with a straight face uh judge
chuckin asked lauro about the things
that Trump said about Bill bar and Mike
Pence and Trump posted a video attacking
bar for not helping him overturn the
election and criticize Pence for not
throwing out electoral votes why does
Fox News constantly put on slowth
thinking and lethargic Bill bar who
didn't have the courage or stamina to
fight the radical left lunatics and she
also wanted Laurel to address Trump's
September 22nd comment about joint Chief
of Staff General Mark Millie Trump said
quote this guy turned out to be a woke
train wreck who if the fake news
reporting is correct was actually
dealing with China to give them a heads
up on thinking of the president of the
United States this is an act so
egregious that in Times Gone by the
punishment would have been death Laurel
said that Trump's commentary about
Millie Pence and bar is acceptable
because quote none of them have ever
suggested that the criticism of
President Trump has led to any
dimunition of their ability to do their
jobs or testify or do whatever they want
to do in terms of criticizing president
Trump just the opposite they give as
good as they take judge chuckin
disagreed quote that's right up to would
no one rid me of this meddlesome priest
if you suggest that someone is deserving
of execution that's not a far stretch to
imagine a situation where one of the
millions of followers of this person
decides to go ahead and do that Laura
responded by saying she hit the nail on
the head and brought up the time that a
deranged Bernie Sanders supporter shot
Steve scalesi uh which really is not
exactly the point that he was trying to
make there lauro said that the gag order
proposed by the government would mean
that Trump couldn't truly campaign
against Joe Biden but even under the
government's proposed order the
prosecutor conceded that Trump wouldn't
be barred from attacking Joe Biden or
Joe Biden's uh justice department but
the government didn't totally have its
way during this hearing the prosecution
sought a very broad gag order that would
have undermined Trump's ability to
challenge the the prosecutions as
politically motivated the doj wanted to
Bar Trump from making any derogatory
statements about the Department of
Justice or mer Garland judge chcken was
reluctant to impose a restriction on
Trump's ability to challenge his
prosecution by the doj quote it seems
awfully close to his right to assert his
innocence and criticize the government
and the Supreme Court emphasized in
Gentile that speech critical of the
exercise of the state's power lies at
the very center of the First Amendment
and while the Government tried to
persuade judge chuckin that Trump's
attacks on the city would somehow
Prejudice the jury pool uh she disagreed
quote this is not about whether I like
the language Mr Trump uses this is about
language that presents a danger to the
administration of justice so after a
two-hour hearing on the motion judge
chuckin issued an order granting the
motion in part and denying the motion in
part quote in order to safeguard the
Integrity of the proceedings it is
necessary to impose certain restrictions
on public statements by interested
parties Undisputed testimony cited by
the government demonstrates that when
defendant has publicly attacked
individuals including on matters related
to this case those individuals are
consequently threatened and harassed the
the judge found that Trump went beyond
merely criticizing the judicial process
he crossed the line by stating that
quote particular individuals involved in
it are liars or thugs or deserve death
the court finds that such statements
pose a significant and immediate risk
that one witnesses will be intimidated
or otherwise unduly influenced by the
prospect of being themselves targeted
for harassment or threats to attorneys
public servants and other court staff
will themselves become targets for
threats and harassment and that risk is
largely irreversible in the age of the
internet once an individual is publicly
targeted even revoking the offending
statement may not the subsequent threats
harassment or other intimidating effects
during the pre-trial as well as trial
stages of this case the judge rejected
Trump's contention that the court can't
limit his speech because he's running
for president quote the bottom line is
that equal justice under the law
requires the equal treatment of criminal
defendants defendants presidential
candidacy cannot excuse statements that
would otherwise intolerably jeopardize
these proceedings and her order applies
to all parties to the case not just
Donald Trump though In fairness it's
only going to affect one person it
limits that
person or people uh from making public
statements that Target prosecutors
defense counsel the court staff and any
reasonably foreseeable Witnesses or the
substance of their testimony but the
judge did allow criticism of herself and
accordingly judge chuckin ordered quote
all interested parties in this matter
including the parties and their Council
are prohibited from making any public
statements or directing others to make
any public statements that Target one
the special councel Prosecuting this
case or his staff two defense counsel or
their staff three any of the Court's
staff or other supporting person or for
any reasonably foreseeable witness or
the substance of their testimony now
that is a gag order but it's not a total
gag order Trump is not prohibited from
maintaining his innocence describing his
prosecution as politically motivated or
criticizing the government now if a
judge finds the defendant has disobeyed
in order of the Court the person can be
found in criminal contempt and criminal
contempt can carry a penalty of days in
jail thousands of dollars in fines or
both the court can also impose stricter
orders and fines a person in violation
of a Court's order can have their bail
revoked meaning meaning that that would
put the person in custody until trial
that's what happened to Sam bankman
freed who was under house arrest while
awaiting trial prosecutor said that
bankman freed tried to intimidate former
FTX CEO Caroline Ellison by publicly
sharing her Diaries and he allegedly
also tried to contact FTX general
counsel Ryan Miller over email and the
encrypted messaging platform signal
which violated the judge's conditions of
release so the judge in that case
revoked his bail but if you're
anticipating that Trump would be put
behind bars for violating any of these
gag orders uh you probably should lower
your expectations given the
circumstances of these cases I wouldn't
expect that to happen unless it was the
most extreme of circumstances and judges
know that keeping Trump from making
disparaging remarks is playing a game of
whack-a-mole but courts do have other
options to CX him into compliance for
example judge chuckin previously
suggested that if Trump cannot follow
the Court's orders she will bump up the
March trial date and it's likely that
Trump doesn't want any of his trials to
happen before the 2024 election and at
the hearing John Loro told judge chuckin
that she could avoid the First Amendment
issues by postponing the trial until
after the general election she brushed
off that suggestion because it's
probably the strongest tool she has to
get Trump to comply but of course as
soon as these gag orders were issued it
seems that they were violated uh we're
now getting a look at just how hard it
is to coordinate a presidential campaign
during a trial uh on October 20th the
New York attorney general alerted judge
angeron that Trump had failed to remove
a post about the judge's law clerk from
his campaign website judge anaran said
quote I learned that the subject
offending post was never removed from
donaldjtrump.com and in fact has been on
the website for the past 17 days uh
incendiary untruth can and have led to
serious physical harm I will now allow
the defendant to explain why this should
not end up with serious sanctions or I
could possibly imprison him he asked
Trump lawyer Chris kais why Trump
shouldn't face serious sanctions and
kais said it was just an accident Trump
had deleted the post from his social
media accounts but it was still on the
campaign website and after a brief
recess Trump's lawyers told the judge
that nobody really saw the post Trump's
lawyers said that the campaign sent
emails to roughly 25,000 recipients but
only around 6,700 of those messages were
open but judge Enron was not amused he
finded Trump $5,000 but warned Trump not
to do it again Trump was quote Way
Beyond the warning stage but since Trump
was a first-time offender he felt that
it was only appropriate to find Trump a
nominal amount and Trump quickly gave
judge Enron another opportunity to ramp
up his fines on the day Michael Cohen
was testifying in the civil case Trump
offered these comments we had a jury it
would have been fair at least even if it
was a somewhat negative jury because no
negative jury would vote against it but
this judge will because this judge is a
very partisan judge with a person who's
very partisan sitting alongside of him
when the judge found out about these
remarks he assumed they were directed to
judge's clerk a clear violation of the
order judge anron said quote it's very
easy for the public to know who that
person is I'm very protective of my
staff as I believe I should be I don't
want anybody to be killed and then the
judge asked Trump's lawyers why there
should not be severe sanctions for this
blatant dangerous disil of a clear court
order Chris Kai said Trump was obviously
talking about Michael Cohen not the
court clerk Kai said that the context
was that Cohen was partisan this seemed
dubious because Trump wasn't discussing
the substance of Cohen's testimony and
Cohen was not sitting next to him it
seemed clear Trump was referring to how
the court was administering the case
that this is a bench trial instead of a
jury trial and that the judge and his
clerk were Trump haters and the clerk is
the one that was sitting close to the
judge uh the judge t discussion the
matter until after the lunch break when
Trump agreed to take the witness stand
where he was put under oath judge Enron
asked Trump who he was referring to and
Trump said you and Cohen the judge said
quote first of all my principal law
clerk is very close to me you and I can
see each other and we are close but not
as close and there's a barrier between
us so wouldn't that at least be somewhat
ambiguous as to whom you are referring
Trump didn't back off of his claim that
he was referring to Cohen which was
probably smart on his part but the judge
said quote as the trior of fact I find
that the witness is not credible and he
finded Trump $110,000 now again this
fine is small in Trump's world but the
overall finding is a big deal the judge
who's going to render a verdict in this
case found that Trump lied to his face
other judges will probably take note as
will the special counsel and speaking of
Judge Chin's case Trump appealed the gag
order to the DC's Circuit of appeals
where he asked for an emergency stay
pending appeal Trump's lawyers also
asked judge chuckin to stay her gag
order while they prepared a full appeal
and judge chuckin issued administrative
stay of her own order and the gist of
Trump's appeal is that the order is
unconstitutional because it limits his
right to engage in core political speech
Trump argues that the part of the order
restricting comments about bar Millie
and Pence is unconstitutional quote the
witnesses that third parties listening
to president Trump have supposedly
intimidated former vice president Pence
former Attorney General bar and former
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
Mark Millie are extremely highlevel
public figures who have voluntarily
entered the public Arena and invited the
cut and thrust of public debate uh by
openly criticizing president Trump thus
the prosecution speculation that these
witnesses will be quote intimidated by
President Trump's criticism is
non-credible on its face and Trump
claims that the government should have
produced affidavits from these Witnesses
ATT testing that they've faced
intimidation and harassment and these
are not crazy arguments Trump got
support from the ACLU which probably
hasn't happened all that many times
before which filed a brief supporting
Trump Anthony Romero director of the
ACLU said quote if we allow his Free
Speech rights to be Abridged we know
that other unpopular voices even ones we
agree with will also be silenced as much
as we disagreed with Donald Trump's
policies everyone is in entitled to the
same First Amendment protections against
gag orders that are too broad and too
vague the ACLU argues that the word
targeting in the judge's order is also
too vague quote in the context of the
order it could mean something as
innocuous as name or identify or
something much more violent uh one could
Target another with respectful but
vigorous political advocacy or Target
them for physical violence or death the
ACLU agreed that there is a serious risk
that Trump's words can Inspire other
people to violence but he contends that
the mere fact that others have
threatened actions against trial
participants after hearing defendants
words is not enough of course surprising
no one after judge chuckin stayed the
order Trump wasted no time in resuming
his commentary on Witnesses and
prosecutors here he is describing Jack
Smith as deranged in a way that would
have violated the original order in the
same post he attacked Anthony Pratt an
Australian businessman who says Trump
shared classified information with him
at maral Lago and Trump also commented
on CD Pal's guilty plea clarifying that
while she was never his attorney she did
a quote Valiant job of representing a
very unfairly treated and governmentally
abused General Mike Flynn which is
interesting because Powell took a plea
deal and is now expected to offer
testimony against Trump in the Fulton
County case and could be a witness in
the case that judge chuckin is presiding
over in Washington DC so judge chuckin
has a conundrum on her hands Trump's
team will brief the court on freedom of
speech issues and prosecutors will
respond but is anyone's guess what will
happen next judge chuckin could
invalidate the original gag order and
issue a more narrowly tailored gag order
uh which could create a whole another
set of appeals uh or maybe not because
it might be so narrowly tailored that
it's not worth fighting over uh or she
could let the original appeal play out
but Trump is wasting no time in issuing
a ton of statements that probably
violate the original now stayed gag
order Trump's comments include calling
Jack Smith deranged he comments on the
substance of Mark Meadow's alleged
testimony and has been lashing out at
cooperating witnesses as weaklings and
cowards but Trump's gag order has been
covered extensively by more than 190
different news outlets and 29% of the
reporting is coming from the left and
21% is coming from the right and if you
compare the headlines you'll start to
see some interesting frames emerge on
the left you have Outlets using
terminology like imposed ordered and
prohibits with reference to the gag
order while on the right you'll find
Outlets using words like slapped with or
hits those word changes are subtle but
they play a big role in how readers
perceive the story the first set of
words might imply Authority and
precedent while the second set of words
might imply something unfair or immature
and all this is possible thank thanks to
today's sponsor ground news a website
app developed by a former NASA engineer
on a mission to give readers an easy
data driven objective way to read the
news at Ground news every story comes
with a quick visual breakdown of the
political bias factuality and ownership
of the sources reporting all backed by
ratings by three Independent News
monitoring organizations I especially
like the ground news comparison feature
which highlights specific differences
between left and right reporting for the
story on Trump's gag order you can see
the left leading Outlets tend to focus
on Trump's legal team opposing the gag
order while the right focuses on
statements by Trump calling the
indictments election interference and a
Witch Hunt now ground news also has a
blind spot feed which highlights stories
that are disproportionately covered by
one side of the political Spectrum this
kind of analysis is so important so we
don't live in an echo chamber or get
misled by subtle and sometimes not so
subtle language in the news so give
ground news A Try by clicking on the
link that's on screen right now ground
news is giving legal eagle viewers 30%
off their Vantage plan this includes
access to a feature called my news bias
which is basically a dashboard for your
news diet you can find out your top news
sources whether you're engaging with
diverse perspectives and what your
favorite topics are so you can try it
out by going to ground. news/ legal
eagle or click on the link that's on
screen right now or down in the
description you can get started for less
than $6 a month and support an
independent news platform working to
make the media landscape more
transparent and after that click on this
link over here for more legal eagle or
I'll see you in court